a stand-up tour one in every crowd will
move on later on this month to port City
Music Hall in Portland Maine where you
know all about that Christopher Brockman
being a main guy over there for men
December second higher ground in South
Burlington Vermont and then a for date
night of December 14th through the 17th
at the American Conservatory Theater in
San Francisco Colin
California Colin Quinn here on the
program good to see you sir good is he
rich
big fan sir thank Sam have been for
quite some time so thanks you're from
Brooklyn right yes okay from Brooklyn
New York
uh-huh I'm just gonna jump straight into
it here okay we I'm from Staten Island
yes I know okay s iny
s s iny Abe v but Forgotten borough here
in New York there are some who believe
Marlon Wayans was on the show last week
said it's not part of New York City ah
technically he slag Don stat I don't
know never said in front of the wu-tang
clan but yeah
it's funny you say that because we did
have Method Man on two weeks oh and I
asked Marlon if he would ever say that
to Method Man he did and there was a
Twitter beef that actually started
hahaha
which is one of my greatest
accomplishments and that is a good where
in life yeah that always in the midst of
a Twitter pp next to the East Coast West
Coast feud you saw the feud between them
and their families its way and since
then they're all members of whoa tang
there you go so what is your take on
Staten Island here yeah I mean sad no
one's always had its own personality
basically it's a it's a social club with
a bridge and listen who's coming across
the Verrazano um yeah I mean Santa has
always been its you can't really put it
into any category it's it's not New
Jersey it's not Brooklyn but it's a
little bit of both you know it's true
it's it's it's always been a psychotic
place you know
that's where I'm from ya know well you
know better than everybody from said
Island knows who I'm saying is yeah it's
true the social club with a bridge is a
great way to describe yeah that is
exactly and like I said I went to the
factory and I went to the Snoopy Sai
Quebec where those with the club's
bright and then early eighties you did
stand-up there's no no she's going there
to socialize a couple of rough
incidences why yes
yeah cuz that was like the big hot rock
club yeah the rock club it's really an
Italian disco borough like but there was
one rock club for thee for the Irish
kids from Richmond yeah sure and um yeah
a guy a couple of friends who grew up
there my dad taught at Port Richmond oh
yeah yeah so I know exactly what you're
talking about but it's it yeah I do
remember growing up in Staten Island
that somebody would drive down my street
Herald Street and Staten Island in their
Cadillac hit the horn in the theme from
the Godfather would did you come up when
you actually cross the Verrazano it's
when you pay the toll that something
should come under $20 toll yeah sort of
thing oh my god so did you ever what
what's your favorite spot to do stand-up
in and one time I met Nick 4002 just to
get to you he's just that not only guy
he was the Ranger enforcing upset not
like that in the days of Ron do a gay
with the flowing hair I would do gay
yeah so you grew up in the garden did
you grow up in the garden no no no I
just happened to run into them at this
thing don't but just we'll go into
Madison Square Garden is you know I
would just watch the games you know the
bread park era those early days of and I
went to what genre tell I'll let you
know yeah and then and I went to a
couple of X Games I was a kid but I
haven't really gone to as many you know
I watch what's on TV you're too lazy
yeah see I feel like my theory on the
Knicks if I could just play which for
one sec guys come quick is that since
they cursed themselves by trying to be
like LA and having celebrities sit on
the sidelines they never used to have
celebrities Woody Allen and Spike Lee
jinx the next those two theory well you
want to ask it a big note you want to
throw Dustin Hoffman in there - does
anyone yes courtside through their walls
Frazier years and all that stuff yeah I
feel like they will front ran in 1970
and started going to Knicks games before
that Denise were golden so else we throw
in this mix McEnroe do we throw Mack and
Roland loves it so John and there even
though I know them but still anybody
that goes to anybody that goes to a lot
of NIC games yes in there get away
you're jinx it's bad energy it's LA
energy
I only supposed to have celebrities at
the game that I think yeah new yorkese
mistake you know I listen to the last
game I was a little kid on the radio
seventh game with Willis Reed in that
famous game and I swear to God I feel
like I saw the whole game you know so
are you Yankee or met
Matt's met like anybody from Brooklyn
Queens I don't you know what
another question Staten Island yes who's
Brooklyn Queens Long Island if you're
not a Jets and a Mets fan yeah you're
kind of a disloyal person right you're
not supposed to be Yankees just they
were great team right but what about
Staten Island where do they fall it's
kind of right in the middle what the
Devils in the know I don't know I don't
know any Devils fans by the way I don't
know a single fan of the New Jersey
Devils I've never met one I don't know
what they look like all and but it used
to be when the Jets and the Mets played
in Shea and the Seas and the Giants
played in Yankee Stadium
but those are that's a different era now
now they all have that differ their own
buildings and now so you'll see a lot
more Yankee jet or met/met giant hybrids
than you've ever seen before it used to
be just straight up from where they used
to play their games yeah not anymore now
you got the nets in Brooklyn
you got the Giants and the Jets in the
same house well that's your weirdest
thing ever by the way you know one it's
been 35 years not crazy
it's been ridiculous why are they not
playing the Citi Field that's a good
question Why ask the Mets it's reading I
don't you have an in with the Mets
I don't work there E yeah yeah you're
right I could this Seinfeld I mean could
could he make a pitching change if he
wants to best you know would your wits I
honestly believe that if he if he if he
wanted to he probably could like if he's
at the game
yeah and syndergaard is struggling right
he knows he could make a call and make
the change
yeah we get syndergaard to cut his hair
but um yeah but the Knicks I'm the only
one to be allowed to go to the next game
by the way I was at a Knicks game in the
front yeah a lot of people would at some
thing in the West Coast right during me
and my nephew and he goes this guy's
coming in is good Jeremy Lin we were
there for the first game of linsanity
insanity courtside Linsanity so but
doesn't that poke a little bit hold on
your theory doesn't I consider myself a
celebrity I consider myself I was a New
York guy or I just I just don't get I
consider myself above that in some way
it's a reverse snobbery and after you by
the way LeBron made me sick yesterday
getting on the subway that in fury
well I want to take a break come back
cuz you were in trainwreck also with her
on calling Quinn here on the Rich Eisen
show will touch upon LeBron James and
more with Colin Quinn again one in every
crowd stand-up tour check it out I am
Colin Quinn on Twitter as well
we're back with Colin here in New York
City and again your phone calls in 60
seconds
all right welcome back to the show eight
four four two Oh for riches the number
two dollar here in New York City will
take your call shortly Colin Quinn
another couple of minutes here with
Colin here in studio how did you get
hooked up with center night live back in
the day um friend of mine Fred wolf was
writing on it he goes you go see him
Lauren saw me I bombed brutally so he
hired me as a writer what do you mean he
saw you do so do stand-up and I bombed
so it was one of the most brutal bombs
and I bombed plenty and but he liked my
right he said oh he's a good writer he
could tell okay so then how did you work
your way from writing and weasel my way
into how did you do um just kiss away it
was new when everybody's just doing
throwing different stuff out say let me
try a couple of things like what like
what what was the ideal Joe Blow she's
really almost a satin I got it was a guy
from Ridgewood at the time in the 90s
right and it was like a regular guy that
I did this lion character it was a lion
it was just coming out of rehab so I was
doing these things on up the line coming
yeah it was a good rehab flying in
something like hey you know he's like
well you know detox lion was you know
Swit norm you know yeah yeah you know a
couple of things you follow norm on
Twitter sure
do you follow his like golf and golf
update second he's like yeah here's your
Spieth for par and then yeah he'll be
like he pars would like fifteen
exhalation points I know it for that's
what I'm wondering I don't know like is
it for you know it's only been on know
it's like it's infuriating but I guess
it's like kind of performance art only
he's not kidding
he's watching every game and every go
and just does it he's probably got
something on it too right I feel he's
got something safely zoom he sees more
riding on it and there is for the
readers oh yeah that's why he's he's
doing exclamation points for games that
are blowouts better all sudden become
closer in the last second Norma Connells
like yes oh my gosh so you did the and
then you took over from what cuz that
was a little bit awkward Oh at the time
I was really ugly when norm ugly yeah
norm got the gate and they turned to you
two yeah yeah
I like at the time was awkward like you
said it was ugly you know yeah I just it
felt weird mm-hmm was a weird energy
okay
sort of like recounting it right now
that's what you're saying yeah okay so
then what was your favorite news update
moment where somebody would come on
things I mentioned before like the lion
and they kill blow thing doing it with
no one was my favorite news um no kiddin
yeah my fault okay I fought
what about anybody else who would come
on and cuz you were there when he died
well Bill Murray came on once that was
kind of wild
okay was I seen him as a kid doing his
update stuff right we just it was so
funny because he didn't hate like it was
just kind of old school like he was like
so casual and just funny in this bull
Murray way right wait I was so exciting
to see that next to it Colin Quinn here
on the Rich Eisen show okay so you were
in trainwreck were you on the set at all
when LeBron was there or your scenes
were now my scenes were not with LeBron
at all right but uh I actually did see
Method Man that we mentioned before huh
and uh but I did no scenes with LeBron
and show me the after-party
and I was like moving past him and I was
like I'm gonna say hello and then he
just gave a little look like oh another
fan and I was like I guess you didn't
see the movie move before I drop you
he's infuriated me ever since that was
it I don't know somebody might have
introduced says maybe we said a brief
you know hello I'm looking at her I
probably gave him a Curt hello occurred
hello and a half a handshake we gave is
he Ray Liotta and Goodfellas and he
shakes hands at the Tennis Club he gave
him one of those yeah all right so there
really was no interactions no love no oh
okay so what you would you you said you
were you had a take on his unhappy I
didn't get to be friendly with him
because apparently got a problem in New
York no walking around on the subway
like his Hiyori the whole team's mocking
attitude on the subway like haha livin
it up on the subway something about it
bugged me and then um and then he said
he's the king in New York which is
heresy right that is true but I kind of
dig it man I mean it's this sort of I
missed the 90s Knicks yes 90s knixwear
Oakley would people put people on their
ass for
attempting to come down a lane like
James Dolan I honestly have nothing but
contempt for that guy
I already said I will not go back to
Madison Square Garden really with my
kids which kind of pains me there
they're wearing Celtics stuff at home
and and I cannot in good conscience go
to that place after Sir Charles Oakley
got his butt dragged I mean he made him
stay a night in jail I missed that those
90s takes larry johnson yeah you know
grandma MA and all those guys and so but
at least this week kind of felt like
that the way they see us to him and then
him is Herc caved in the fourth quarter
the Turk and the French oh I know the
Turk in the French guy the United
Nations the Turk in the French guy
really stood up to a LeBron but here's a
know like okay this is my own theory yes
and I hate it when Jordan did it yeah
when you're LeBron or Jordan you don't
get to trash-talk people you're the
greatest player me you're in the top
five of all time you grains playing the
league right now yeah you know I've seen
you see Jordan walking up quite like
crashed or guys like yeah I know you're
Jordan you scored on me right no one's
surprise it's you don't get to
trash-talk
when you're those guys so you don't you
don't like him allowed to hmm you know I
I kind of like I said I thought it was
fun then at that moment on the Segway
this for a moment on the subway it was
one of the most New York moments right
where the guy does not know who he is
it just doesn't want to be on the phone
of LeBron James it doesn't matter and I
just loved it on the New York side till
he said yeah don't put me on your the
paranoia the New York paranoia is on
display I love that part you know even
when there's like nine seven-foot guys
just walked onto the sign oh you know
and they're and they're right there with
their phones and dudes like I don't even
want to be on here get me out of here I
know yeah the attitudes right great
Colin Quinn here on the Rich Eisen show
ok so who's the best stand-up
of all time what do you think I mean to
all out to most of us
tell em sweet for everybody I'll speak
for everybody it's prior and George
Carlin those are the guys that just
transcend any you know Lenny Bruce Emily
booze we know a lot of people like all
Lenny Bruce wasn't that fun
Lenny booze changed the game like nobody
else did so you have to give credit to
that so it's Lenny Bruce Richard Pryor
if it's the Mount Rushmore that's weird
you Pryor George Carlin and it was the
fourth ah maybe Don Rickles I mean Don
Rickles was not materials material
wasn't great right but he was just so
funny
every time out you don't mean right you
just have to put him somewhere whose
talk show do you always want to do the
most because of the stand-up friendly
environment of somebody's talk show
late-night show there anybody now
nobody's nobody's I mean which one do I
want to do you mean know which one that
you have done that you thought it was
always fun to do I don't care I mean
yeah I don't care I mean stand up but
I'm a field once again I'm the only
speaking for all comedians everybody but
I feel like talk shows you have to be
kind of on you know you have to cover
everything just you have to be in the
best-behaved wars when you do in
stand-up is more like the way we're
talking now so you and your best
behavior right now no I'm saying okay
walking you trying to be funny but you
really you know but in stand-up is like
so you know it's just too formal for my
taste and I think a lot of most
comedians feel okay never get dressed up
cuz I know more satine young comic was
great and his first time TVs got a suit
he's like this right and still you know
I can see that norm was Letterman's
choice to be his last yeah I thought
that was pretty that was a funny bit too
about I was great well what - well which
one the funniest bit I thought of norms
that he said was how the your phones
change everything now right that is a
picture he's got one grainy picture of
his great grandfather like separating
the hogs on the farm right but now
because everybody's got a phone right
now somebody from years to now here's 1
million pictures of my
great-grandfather's right everything in
their life enormous face when he did his
grandfather he's horrified horrified
that someone's taking this picture just
looking like shock like gonna take my
picture
yeah I know but let me do the Hitler bit
- I not only challenges the world and
then they fought the world again yeah
those are copies and Hitler a comedy
killer though wouldn't you that'd be one
of those things that hidden me Oh
Hitler's like there's no common
I mean not anymore I feel like just the
opposite I feel like there's almost fake
shock sometimes where it's like people
yeah I mean so it's like that's almost
like a comedy helper in some ways right
not no not that way no I'm did it that
was a different bit I was a really a bit
so did you guys tell 240 you guys know
the same people the same people yeah we
do from MTV TV yeah we know from MTV the
ladies back of your remote control day
yep I did one day tone I think you were
at yeah I was at two Daytona's yeah
eighty Spring Break MTV 7:01 South the
club right in the back yeah Janek that
he insane it was insane you know I'll
tell you who was speaking of athletes
who was always there judged every
contest Jim Kelly I know Jim Kelly and
everything God bless God question well
Jim Kelly great story about Jim okay is
that the Pro Football Hall of Fame and
Canton Ohio they used to have a age that
the guys would just sit there in the hot
Sun and they would sit there and do
nothing just roast while all the
speeches was going on so Jim basically
said hey we need we need some beverages
here so they would have something off to
the side that they would sometimes get
up you'd wonder where these home favors
go and they go off to the side and Jim
would have all these beers and
everything set up right there until they
built a new stage now it's underneath
this like of Jim Kelly like greenroom
stage where these guys speak and then
the year that he he missed a little bit
of time cuz you know he had cancer and
is doing well right now knock on wood we
came back the one year he came back and
he was he was there and everybody
thought maybe Jim might not be there
because of his health we were there one
night in a hotel and Canton and he was
behind a bar and I loved it there was
one bartender who was very overwhelmed
and everyone was in there yeah because
we're serving out and Jim got behind the
bar serving drinks oh yeah oh yeah and
and you might say you know how some
service we some
bars where you got that little cup the
port in the cup the Jim Jim was just
don't help of course any more money Jim
is his realization speaking of spring
breaking Buffalo Bills by the way yeah
so one time they go like this and I have
no psychic I never had an intuitive
psychic moment yeah
they go middle vf2 in crowded with
people coming out of a limo with a girl
you want to meet OJ I go yeah unless
Tammy no J I shook his hand and my whole
body was like shocked with like evil
middle yeah that was weird I loved OJ
was the greatest running back ammo top
that one was this back in the was a
place to be yeah it was everybody couple
weeks remote control was such a fun show
oh yeah it was the only thing I've ever
done was it as easy as it looks like we
would just show up and just all right so
uh I am Colin Quinn on Twitter go ahead
and follow him check him out again port
City Music Hall in Portland Maine on the
30th of this month and December 2nd in
South Burlington Vermont and then the
middle of December for dates that the
American Conservatory Theater in San
Francisco California like I told you big
fan thanks for coming out thank you
you got a Colin Quinn here on the Rich
Eisen show the Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience